good morning Hank it's Tuesday bonus
video time so while I was in Ethiopia I
filmed several videos where I talked to
Bill Gates about stuff in this one we
talked about health care I'm going to be
uploading these every Tuesday for the
next month or so a couple hours before
my regular vlog brothers video so enjoy
the bonus and you know the Bill Gates
I'm wondering if you can just kind of
talk me through what you just saw on
what your questions were what you find
encouraging about that and any concerns
that you have these primary health care
facilities are how we've taken child to
death down from about 25% of all
children now about 5%
getting the vaccines out so that every
child gets all these vaccines that's
really hard they have to be kept cold
and of course most poor kids live in
very rural areas where there's not very
good roads not many trained workers so
Ethiopia created a system where as the
lowest level there's a health post and
here we're at this health center some of
the regions particularly where people
our pastor will move around a lot that's
still where they have less than 30
percent vaccination rate the rest of the
country is up at about 75% there's a
plan to get it up to 90% so can you talk
about a little bit about how how we know
that the reduction in infant mortality
is related to this dramatic improvement
in sort of last mile health care to the
grief the statistics from poor countries
are often very poor the one statistic
that's really good is the number of
children who died tragically in a lot of
countries that was very very high and
because it was a limited number of
infectious diseases by getting the right
vaccines these poor countries we've cut
those death rates down a lot
another huge tragedy beyond death is
that even the kids who survived don't
physically or mentally fully develop and
there you've got a lower the burden of
disease a lot you've got to get good
sanitation and you've got to get good
food now the other thing about health is
that is more children survived amazingly
mothers choose to have less children and
so the whole population growth challenge
which is can I feed can i educate can I
provide jobs that becomes more
achievable and then you get out of the
poverty trap and so health is not the
only thing but it is
invite you the central thing the thing
you really have you have to get that
right or else the country will not be
able to keep its children alive and
support itself
[Music]